>> Izzy: Hi Dude!
What are you up to?
>> Dude: I'm picking a promoter
to use to in Buddy.
I need a promoter that is always
on that will make Buddy be red.
>> Izzy: So why are you poking
at the computer screen?
>> Dude: Well how else do I pick one?
I don't know which one to use so I
figured I'd leave it to chance to decide.
>> Izzy: Well why don't you use some of the
promoter characterization data available
on the Registry of Standard
Biological Parts to decide?
>> Dude: What is promoter measurement data?
>> Sally: Hi Dude.
Hi Izzy. Sounds like you two are
having an interesting conversation.
>> Izzy: Yeah.
I was just about to tell Dude how
to use promoter measurement data
to pick the right promoter for Buddy.
>> Sally: Well before you get into those
details it might be worth chatting a bit
about measurement in general.
Why synthetic biologists measure part function?
What measurements they make and how
they do the measurements before getting
into the details of the data itself?
>> Izzy: That's true!
>> Sally: Why don't we take a walk?
Get some fresh air while we talk.
Measurement is a key aspect
of science and engineering.
It lets you quantify the
function of a part or component
and compare its function to that of others.
Unfortunately in synthetic
biology, we're still figuring
out what are the most useful measurements
to make for genetic parts and devices.
>> Dude: What do you mean?
Why don't we just measure
everything for every part?
>> Sally: Well that can pretty quickly lead both
to a lot of wasted time in making measurements
that don't matter as well as an
overwhelming amount of information.
Ideally, we'd like to be able to only measure
those characteristics of a part that you need
to know in order to decide whether the
part will work in your system of interest.
>> Izzy: For example, when I
bought a computer recently,
I cared about how big the hard drive
was and how much memory it had,
because those were two performance
metrics that I could use to figure
out whether the computer would
be sufficient for my needs.
>> Dude: Well in the case of
Buddy, I just need to know
which promoter to use that will make him red.
>> Izzy: But how red do you want Buddy to be?
Should Buddy be pink, red, or dark red?
To make decisions like that, you
might need to know a bit more
about how strong the promoter is.
>> Sally: Exactly.
Another measurement you might care about is
how long the part works before it breaks.
Genetic parts can "break"
as Buddy grows and divides.
For example, mutations or deletions can
happen that interfere with part function.
So depending on how long you expect Buddy
to stick around, you might choose promoters
that are more or less genetically stable.
>> Dude: Whoa!
I had no idea that measuring part
function could be so complicated!
Well I think I am going to find myself
a strong promoter from the registry.
I've decided that I want
Buddy to be very dark red!
>> Sally & Izzy: Have fun!
>> Sally & Izzy: Jinx!